c'est un fils trop influent trop donc
d'y mettre 10 mètres de long 2 mètres 50
de large donc on lui a donné des
dimensions un peu xxl parce que on
voulait gagner en stabilité
c'est en voisin que le skolvan s'invite
au festival de loire se battent aux
effets du bois des copains et de
l'association chemins d'eau
c'est nous qui l'avons construit donc on
ya mis du coeur on est amis à un petit
peu de douceur donc voilà donc on sait
un panier de ce bateau être capitaine
d'un bateau au port de comble c'est un
lien profond avec la batellerie de loire
depuis sa mise à l'eau en 2014 philippe
delaunay a vu beaucoup d'eau passer sous
la coque est manifestement ça crée des
liens les amoureux de son bateau que
c'est vraiment l'amour dans la marine de
loire et quand on est fusionnelle comme
ça on fait toujours très attention à
tout ce qui est sur le bateau tout ce
qui tourne autour et tous les gens tous
les gens qui peuvent être dessus ça il
est très attentif à ce qui se passe
autour de son bateau qui sont sa
deuxième maison qu'on veut dire croatie
dire la pallière sa maîtresse mais ça
pourrait
c'est quand même une affaire de famille
il suffit d'écouter la fille de philippe
évoqué son père et son bateau
super disponible
pour son bateau pour sa loire c'est
hyper présent c'est papa bateau papa
bateau quoi c
est obligatoire
c'est toute sa vie au revoir madame
baptisé le skolvan le futro porte avec
lui tout un mode de vie ce col pour pour
la convivialité pour trinquer en
scandinave et et le vent pour pour
coller à la rivière donc voilà salut
c'est un bateau qui en état c'est un
bateau qui répondent donc aux critères
des bateaux traditionnels donc donc il
est bien là et a complètement sa place
mais et c'est avec une grande fierté que
notre marnier présente son fût trop au
public